[Music]
we already start welcome everyone to the
endgame class tonight and we'll take a
look at a lot of Indian positions and I
really like end games because I when I
grew up a lot of my coaches they spend a
lot of time helping me to learn all
kinds of in games so in a world champion
Tigran Petrosian school that I went to
when I was a kid they put a lot of
emphasis on the end games so I you know
always felt pretty comfortable about end
games you know and you know in general I
knew what I need to do so this one
example I have will do different kinds
of end games today so this one example
is a game and this game is played
between two very strong grandmasters
this is a chaplain of grandmas a
chaplain from Bulgaria and Greece shook
and here this shook is block and looks
like block is better because after the
move be tree for example here if you
exchange King takes between then they
you play a 2 and a 1 and you're going to
be able to Queen the pond ok so that's
why it's so the idea is he wants to play
b3 so you have to find a way here to
make a draw and the idea is to use a
fortress fortress is if you're not very
familiar with it it's a it's basically a
position where opponent could have extra
material but he cannot really make
progress so there will be a few other
examples on the fortresses today so so
let's think little bit here to try to
understand what we need to do here
because he Stratos to play b3 right and
let's say you play h7 he just plays he
just plays
be three takes and even though your pawn
is actually further advanced but you
cannot do anything to stop his pawn from
cleaning if you try the move Bishop d1
he will simply play the move Bishop to
h8 Bishop is blocked and then you play A
two A one and your clinic okay
that is the idea so let's see here the
team is called fortress fortress is
again you will be done a lot of material
but you'll be able to come up with some
kind of a position where opponent cannot
break through Aashish okay okay let's
see Bishop takes before you're
sacrificing your bishop you realize that
okay now I take King King D - correct
so the bishop sacrifice is the correct
idea
so what White is trying to do here if
black King reaches B - square you will
lose your pawn and the game as well so
that's why what is he's trying to do
here is trying to prevent that from
happening so he's trying to block White
King from reaching there so now he goes
here and now let's say he is waiting a
little bit
yeah King D - or you can actually do the
bestest tool for you to stay here you
stay here on b1 yeah even though he goes
here you continue pushing to spawn you
actually well you don't need the pawn
anymore you can even give this pawn away
so he will every time he goes here what
did we see here still mate okay so it's
it's still made so it's amazing that he
has a bishop and a pawn and even if he
has more pants on a file this position
he cannot win C he can play this move
and force you to give up the pawn so but
in this position you just stay here the
only way you know the only way you can
lose this if you play a really terrible
move here like only way to lose here is
actually if you go to the corner yeah
it's like you know yourself you
self-made yourself you know that's the
only way you can lose this game it's
it's it's very similar to the position
with two knights okay okay
with two knights also right let me set
up an example for you so this is correct
so so one second Ashish so so same thing
is with two knights yeah let me show you
so it's a draw but you can lose it so
there's two knights of everybody here
know that two Knights versus a king with
no pants as a draw okay so this is
theoretical draw but you still have ways
to lose it but again it's similar you
have to make a really terrible mistake
at the end to lose this so let me show
you how it's gonna work so let's say he
goes here you will go here then he will
go here so so he will basically give you
a check something like this check if you
go here it's a draw
but if you make the mistake to go here
then you bring the knight in to mate so
that's why these positions I don't think
you can claim a draw if you're playing
other thing you can stop the car you say
oh this is a theoretical draw you still
have to play the 50 moves to make the
draw other wise you know you still have
ways to lose so to speak okay so that so
you saw that one position with the pawn
on a two-block pot on a tree in the dark
square bishop that's a one draw for you
via a fortress idea okay I have another
position for you most of you should not
disposition this is another endgame
where it seems like there shouldn't be
any question about who is winning here
white is up a bishop plus he's got extra
pawn but guess what is the evaluation of
this position with correct play for both
sides sure can absolutely this position
is called the wrong it's a wrong color
bishop this bishop is the wrong color it
has to be dark square bishop to be able
to win so that's why this is a wrong
colored bishop and that's why this
position is a draw let me show you how
it's draw so a king comes up it seems
like you can start making some progress
so you push
and now again you can always go to the
wrong square yeah endless but if you go
here this position cannot be won because
the bishop cannot push the King away
from the dark square so remember the
side pants you have to be very very
careful because sometimes even with the
extra bishop you cannot win this
position even if you have couple of more
pounds on an h-file you still cannot win
this position this there is one position
you could win by using a restriction
idea that is this position if let's say
he's not being careful he stays there
right there's one position you can win
look let's say opponent is not being
careful he doesn't go to the corner so
you make a waiting movement now he goes
here right guess what now he's losing
see he has to be careful here who can
show me the win here yes h6 now now
you're telling him that he's not gonna
go back that easily so he is gonna try
to get here go via this direction here
now another neat move needed here to win
to win this game continue yes not this
way because this way he were walking to
c6 g6 ok Bishop to h7 absolutely now
you're covering the squares so the King
can I get there now he goes here
again if you make one mistake he's gonna
get that position what do you do here to
avoid that mistake
what is the correct king h5 correct
now all the scores are taken you're
slowly pushing the King back so he goes
here I think it may be this this is fine
to just satisfy to now absolutely now
after the King arrives to g7 now it's a
win because what do you do you move the
bishop away and you queen so again in a
theoretically drawn positions it's still
this is I'm showing you this so you you
know you avoid messing it up and losing
also you play it out until the end maybe
your opponent will make a mistake so you
don't you know you're not you know will
be you're not facing the grandmasters
where you know oh it's you know it's
theoretical draw you shake hands know
you play it out because it's still the
chance it's still a chance I've seen
people go wrong and make mistakes in an
endgame so yeah King he was just not
being careful if he would have stay in
the corner so if you're defending just
staying in the corner remember just stay
in the corner don't go away from the
corner then there's nothing he can do to
win this okay so because now he doesn't
have a way to get you out of here unless
he you know he still makes you that's
the only way he can do it okay everybody
understand this position this is called
wrong color Bishop okay
wrong color Bishop position okay okay
here white to play the difference of
this position here is if the rooks are
existing with the rooks existence on the
board
two knights and rook can easily win this
position okay two nights and a rook can
easily win against the rook and a king
yes if the rooks are swapped up then yes
you'll be able to make a draw possible
but what's the idea here for you to try
to win this
I'm sorry white to play you wanna try to
draw this it's very creative idea yeah
okay please raise your hand first and
let me call you first
okay so rook c7 check I don't see this
what is this will do let's say I go here
yes but then I go here so let's say then
you run out of checks and now I will
start to bring my pieces in to
consolidate them you know to consolidate
them so what do you do here white to
play and you want to achieve a position
where you'll be able to make a draw here
but it's not a a it's not so simple it's
it's a very nice move here that you need
to find to achieve a theoretically drawn
position to achieve a position that will
be theoretically drawn again Luke to h5
look at that move sacrificing the rook
if he takes you you take and this is a
draw and by the way if he doesn't take
your pawn the best move is for you to
push this pawn because some positions
you can lose this if your opponent's on
a fourth rank it's blocked you can lose
this on the sixth rank it's a draw
okay
yes yes yes yes so night takes of course
right that's the question now of course
if I take this you know there's nothing
there's nothing if there is nothing even
to discuss here you know there's nothing
even to discuss here so black will win
this but now can what is your follow-up
you push the pan and you drop the rock
you see with very few pieces on the
board you have a very nice idea you're
using some tactical ideas to make a draw
otherwise you would lose this game so
what this tells you is when you're
playing chess you always have to keep
your imagination on ya always look for
something creative you can never you
know say oh it's already over yes yes
yes yeah it's a very very creative way
of making a draw here yes it's a
smothered rook absolutely correct and
the problem is now let's say he moves
takes and now we have the theoretically
again drawn position got it okay now the
next position we have so everybody
understand this position if you don't
play rook h5 you can try to play this
but you will lose because two nights in
a row eventually will you're just too
strong too much power right to play and
draw yeah you can't really win this
because you know you can put a bishop on
d5 King comes in I mean you're you're
you're in serious risk of losing this
game you are in serious risk of losing
this
well he's gonna go Bishop d5 next move
and he's gonna unpin that I'm you know
right now you haven't cut but he can't
play we should be five and there's no
longer gonna be a cut
so what is the move here it's white to
play yes
King F - the problem with them always he
goes Bishop d5 and now he's gonna cross
and he just probably gonna come here and
when you're a pawn it's got that F pawn
to use as a deflection or a decoy
you know like slowly he will it will
penetrate in with the King on c2 and I
think that might be able to win this
sure that's let's see let's try here I
just go here now
and this pond is still there if you
didn't have this pond yes you'll
accomplish the drill but now he just
push push you're gonna have to sacrifice
the rook at some point and f-pawn will
still win okay so basically passive
defense is not going to work we have to
be creative here yes Luke h5 okay push
possibly push
it takes ok you have Czech and rugby six
so you have that actually ok I can't
play this yet ok but let me just go
Bishop let's say here first
well then I get that my king can come in
now
well now I can come right and then play
f2 okay
yes why can't it - sure
and if Bishop d5 the point is if you
come this way then I can start using to
activate my king and I start using this
guy this guy is pretty far advanced too
so I have I have to I will have
eventually to pass pawns
it'll be very hard to prevent both of
them it's not like he wins immediately
but he will win gradually now gradually
he will win this try to remember the
first position you had today and see if
you can do something similar to the
first position in this one because you
learn that there could be some kind of
fortresses there right so see if you can
make something similar Adie
okay rook takes c4 it seems like this
just loses to Bishop h6 right
it looks like rookies gone the game is
over but now is it over King after he
perfect he has to take it now we take it
but it's a race race begins whoever gets
to here D 2 square will win the race I
wait I wait for a mistake
I I wait huh
and now you should ditch me I say no I
wait I try to somehow shoulder it in and
I just try to get it somehow so yeah
once the king is on a1 it's a dead girl
yeah so yeah so you know we always talk
about having a pawn wedge you know the
pawn on the third rank or sixth rank
it's always an advantage but sometimes
in an endgame like when there is only a
few pieces left it could be a
disadvantage you know it's advantage the
most of the time to have a pawn like
that you know near near near you know on
a sixth rank or on third rank but
sometimes in English as we're seeing in
these few examples it could be also a
disadvantage sometimes so this position
again cannot be won very similar to the
first position that you've seen okay
a very good question from Claudia let's
see here let's change this to a dark
square Bishop I think this is a win but
I'm not 100% sure okay so with light
square Bishop is a drill but this is a
clear and not that easy question is this
a winner
Turing doesn't matter you can get any
any position you want you turn let's say
it says move you can I think it's a draw
still yeah I know but the thing is I'm
not going to take it if I take it as
sheesh yes
but I go King b1 like you almost need
like two moves if you need to move King
go C to Bishop on a3 then I have to take
it you understand
so if the bishop comes on a3 I won't
take it but if your King comes closer to
me then it's a stalemate so I think this
is a draw I really don't see a way to
make Pryor okay of course I could win if
your king is not on a1 if your king is
done on a one I can win that I would
keep the bishop in a way but here so
even with both color bishops looks like
this is a draw we don't need the engine
Ashish you know just just try to you
know try to see if you can find ideas
yeah yeah just just try to see ideas
what are the ideas there two ideas here
Bishop before a bishop a tree right the
problem is is just no ideas Ashish
Bishop c3 same thing same exact thing
don't take it that don't take it you
take it you lose it
what's the difference
so we it's a win anyway so nobody goes
King we won I don't see a way off to
make progress here
then you will win no but okay if it goes
here you don't have to but here you can
take it already as long as you know your
king and pawn and game we can take it
okay all right so another position okay
a lot of people actually don't study too
much fortresses that's why I picked this
topic today because a lot of people you
know don't know you know like even what
fortress is where it really accomplishes
but there's so many positions you can
save you know to make a half a point
I'll show you another position here even
some very strong players that I talked
to grandmasters you know like they had
no idea about the next position I'm
gonna show you that that position is
actually drawn so let's look at this one
now so you're playing with black pieces
obviously two bishops are stronger than
the rook two bishops are very very
powerful but here you're gonna be able
to come up with an idea to you know
you're gonna come up with an idea to
make a draw here
what idea can you do here to make a draw
same idea as which haha but but yeah but
how do how do we get there that's the
question okay I should go ahead our ship
says 'if I've okay now the point is if
you just capture it rook Bishop is
saying you will drop the bishop if you
move the bishop
takes
are you sure Ashish what did you do
actually made me lose see you lose the
food roof my friend it was the full rock
now this I slowed down it's not about
being fast it's about being accurate
okay so the first book is correct right
but now what's the next idea here well
if you give up the rook it's a problem
yeah
look a tree let's try not to drop our
root guys you know just this is not the
wrap our rope please rookies under
attack so can you move the rook
somewhere to gain a tempie every Tempe
right guys I did I just don't go there
Bishop's are strong because they can
what pin and pier so just try to avoid
putting it somewhere near your king okay
okay but if you just go away I take your
opponent this is going to be a problem
you're gonna lose the game
sheesh
ticks see I'm gonna push it I'm not
gonna take it push it and this is of
course winning position okay something
better something better here I want to
see yes rook to a7 attacking the bishop
excellent so if I move the bishop you
take my last pawn that's gonna be a draw
no question there so we got to continue
with this move
absolutely you keep attacking it now if
it goes this way you go rook c3 and you
know you can just just evil take no puns
left here okay
and if he goes Bishop d6 again don't be
get creative with this you know because
that's what I'm just gonna take and just
stay with the same out concept you go
here and now again take take and you go
here got it
okay now let's continue with this f5 of
course
and now dono ashes you've been slipping
on this one black to move now you have
to remember those fortresses right see
if you can get another fortress like
that
yes correct correct yes and now you
don't need the pawn right get rid of it
get rid of the pawn and this is actually
that same position cloud you remember
you say that this is a position where
the color is but it's a draw so that
tells you that's your confirmation
ashish you know that's your confirmation
that this position is drawn another
example we see here okay all right I
have a question for you here and this is
a very interesting question again this
is what I mentioned a lot of people
don't know about this I can give you a
position you have a Bishop Knight versus
king and queen who knows the position
who knows the position where it's a draw
the fortress position here not so many
people know this they're even
grandmasters don't know this or you know
international masters so very strong
players it's just I happen to study this
a long time ago and it's a very good
thing for to know you know for knowledge
no no no no I'm just asking you first
before I set up the position maybe
somebody knows anybody have an idea a
position you can put your pieces
anywhere you want the white pieces
Bishop a knight and a king and you can
say hey this position is a fortress have
you seen anything like this you have
this is not a position but you can yes
Adi that's fortress okay let's see
so Adi Adi claims that this might be a
fortress but okay idea I then play so
you're just gonna go back and forth sort
of okay let's say you go there I go
first thing I put the Queen here you
cannot move too much now right then I
start moving Adi
or see - I mean no I was just just an
example you know there's you must you
cannot move the night you move the
bishop I take your mate
okay so your Fortis guys should be some
way that the King cannot get too close
like that okay
if the King is too close like that that
doesn't work okay any other suggestions
any other creative still made ideas yes
okay all right let's try let's try your
fortress so something like this right
okay so I'm gonna let's say it's your
turn you move here or so I will go here
okay so I start bringing my piece in
not easy you know all right
can you eat b1 meet an hour before you
got to figure out the position where the
King cannot come so close night on b1
sure let's give it another try and then
I'll show you the I'll show you the real
fortress okay this okay buddy this is
very similar to the previous positions I
just bring the Queen down okay let's say
you go here and I just start bringing
the King in so you so you will sit right
or I don't know here I start bringing in
I keep this here
King reaches on b-tree it's over okay
Claudia what about you any ideas okay so
let's say I'm a king is here my queen is
somewhere here something like this so
you're gonna go like this sort of okay
so this idea okay let me try to go here
first so your turn you go here I go here
this is already sucks Lamia yeah
so check Claudia this is about that so
so the way the fortress works here it's
same setup but instead of the night only
one night is on d4 okay now what happens
here is bishop controls this squares and
night control this course you know so
it's like it's the king is barricaded so
there's no way there's no way to get
closer to him
your move Knight boo looks bit awkward
on a1 I'm afraid there might be some
kind of Suk's along there here here it's
you know here it's you know for sure
this is a fortress here so now let's say
he tries to win this yes so he goes here
check check of course don't go here now
now I just go here here we're not as
cramped you know as the position with
the knight on a one I don't know one
with a little bit Crump the King has no
scores to go to either so here if you
see it I sit if you sit I sit if you go
here now what is the move here what is
the only move here no King III queen b1
he gets behind it
oh yeah yeah absolutely Bishop a1
correct yes and look at that again
everything is taken
yes that's why they say night belongs in
the center remember that's another
example for you night belongs in the
center check back
don't block the bishop don't block the
bishop because you'll take your night
all right
only when it's trivial
only when it's trivial like you got you
you know like there is absolutely like
you know it also a little bit depends
who you're playing if you're playing
let's say you know mm really players 90
90 player and you're like down to a
queen and a pawn and he's got like a lot
of extra pieces yeah you can probably
resign there but if you close you know
if you close you see some still matrix
some things try it out you know I always
recommend my students you know you know
especially the young students they're
always mistakes happening you know
people go fast a little bit they miss
some still made ideas so this you always
see I'm never surprised you know when I
see like you know somebody's totally
losing then he comes back and makes a
draw so at the moment unless you're
already like twenty to twenty three
hundred level just play it out play
around I mean yeah if it's like
completely losing position where you're
like you have nothing left
you just have a king left and upon and
he's got like rooks queen you know yes
you're resigned well there was a there
was a game I was watching there was a
grandmaster playing online and he was
just totally winning and then he tries
to show off try to get multiple Queens
you know instead of just meeting and
then he just suddenly promotes another
Quillin to steal mate but it's a weird
one because his opponents didn't had a
pawn you know but when he promoted he
pinned them you know so he couldn't say
was you know but yeah I would suggest
play it out you know play it out until
you're like for sure you know you lost
you know
because strange things happen in chess
even like when grandmaster splits it's
in all kinds of you know so similar
fortress is this way right so just try
to take a picture of this position or
write it down because I think I'm to be
useful for you to notice that this is a
fortress
okay Knight has to be in the middle
supported by the bishop and King in a
corner that is another fortress okay for
you situation yeah well actually
actually I've had a game one of my
students was playing a game and he is a
strong player like international master
and he didn't know about this you know
and he had no idea like you know like
that he can actually get this because he
was just shuffling around trying to come
up with something instead you know he
had the chance maybe to get this
position and then it would have been a
draw so I've seen actually actual game
in a queen you know because sometimes
the pawn queens and then you have you're
trying to chop his pants so you take all
his pants and he queens and the thing is
this is very important for two reasons
not only for the defense but also when
you have the Queen you know which
position you need to try to prevent from
happening so you're not just learning to
draw learning how to you also avoid this
position because if you avoid this most
likely most likely you will win this one
this one I know for sure there is
there's no way to make progress I mean
there's just no there's no way to get
closer question is if you can get to
this position that's that's never tricky
but you can okay alright the next
position we have here is black to move
and here play with the block pieces he
is completely winning here yeah so his
last move was the careless move King be
six he probably thought there is no
difference I mean I have three extra
pawn there's no way I'm not gonna win
this game
and now suddenly you have an
unbelievable way of making a drawer
here because it's just it just looks
trivially here three connected past
pounds with the night being able to
protect I mean it just looks completely
over but now you will see and learn
another fortress here okay you will see
and learn another fortress here that you
could use in your games head he played
had he played the move night before he
would have you to win the game had he
had played that move no it's a draw draw
draw for white haha so you're trying to
do a stalemate huh okay all right think
think yeah yes
Bishop f5 okay that's the most natural
move and he's gonna play ninety five but
then I take then I will bring the King
here and promote okay so claudia has an
interesting idea so it's done a bishop
pass what do you suggest Bishop takes
this is interesting sacrificing the
bishop so I take now you take what the
question is which pawn yeah that's a big
question though yeah you grab this one
you're gonna lose for sure F fun is too
strong so you grab this one buddy but it
still it should be a window it seems
like it but what do you do in g3
attacking the pawn
now he goes here and now if he had the
same problem he can never access the
squares you know because if he does that
it's gonna be a yeah it's gonna be a
stalemate got it so there is one more
trick here I can try to do here to win
this I can play the move H to try to
lure you in you know lure you into take
my h2 pawn because then I have the F
pawn is a win here f3 Knight takes your
back to this position and again this
position is a draw
that's why Knight is not as strong as
you know a bishop for example because
positions like this you see another
example is especially here see if when
you take he doesn't have enough time to
protect this if you had if you can get
an either in g5 he will protect it but
he doesn't have time to get there okay
so that's another fortress position for
you to remember okay all right and our
last position for today wide to play and
draw you down a queen full rook here but
if you know this idea you're gonna be
able to make a draw and it's right now
if you don't do it right now it's gonna
be over no no the pawn is going this way
so what do you do you have to make sure
you setup the cut here Adie
aha Rock f3 now the king is cut cannot
cross if he sacrifices the Queen for the
pawn in a crook he cannot win because
it's a side pawn so he goes he goes here
continue locates you just sit all you
got to do is go back and forth back and
forth
that's all you got to do okay so he
pushes again absolutely oh that's all
you do if it checks you don't think
about blocking with the rook okay you
got to keep the cut there okay so King
h2 and now what do you do
absolutely okay this is what you got to
remember a position like this you bring
the rook here cut and if it's a H pawn
he cannot win if we push this pawn one
square up same position it's a win okay
if we had this position Khan has to be
on g2 it has to be on its original
square if it's like this you achieve the
same thing
this is a losing position because what's
going to happen here he's gonna be able
to go behind it okay
behind it and then yeah like he's gonna
check let's say you play here check and
see he's gonna attack you attack you and
get behind because now he can get it but
the original position he doesn't have
space to do that
okay so part has to be on its original
square to achieve a draw okay okay very
good well thank everybody for attending
this class and we'll see you on Thursday
you
[Applause]
[Music]